hello hello this is Adam Smith from the
Nobel foundation's website erica is this
a possible time to talk quickly sure
thank you so congratulations of course
on the award of the Nobel Peace Prize to
the Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change thank you what do you think the
Nobel Peace Prize means to the IPCC or
do they mean to the IPCC or to the world
either or both well I mean for the IPCC
it's really a big honor and you know it
just provides an enormous amount of
encouragement to all the scientists and
experts who work tirelessly to produce
the reports of the panels and I mean
this is an honor that no one could have
anticipated and as far as the world is
concerned I think it's very clear
message that climate change is extremely
important could you just hold half a
minute certainly yes do you end up just
roughing it of course yes well they can
call 15 minutes later yeah sorry yeah I
think as far as the world is concerned I
think the very clear signal that the
Nobel Prize Committee is clearly
indicating that climate change is
something that needs attention it's a
serious problem and it therefore
requires urgent attention from the world
and the global community
you